oh just in time 14:13 okay got my tea
green tea blueberry slim like crocodile
well hi raiden okay this is gonna be
much different from classical c4 oh it's
two minutes I thought was one minute two
minute that changes things so much time
to think
let's play this move and this move my
bishop should go back clay this a force
coming okay we can trade ya the bishop
should return me g3 time management is
very very important also holding on to
pawns is kind of important too it's a
good move
before possible hmm I'm gonna sack the
pawn can't have time I don't have time
to calculate everything this is more of
an intuitive decision it takes I play
this I would hopefully win the pawn back
my e4 play this move on e4 is kind of a
surprise play this
so I'm down upon the d66 things are
opening up five interesting steak
tacking a bishop now I'm winning d6 a b2
falls in the end I can defend it now
this is falling it's going to be an
endgame time scramble I'll play b3 when
I got the chance let's play f3
a spawn okay
now the great starts I do realize it's
two minutes while I'm playing another
good player oh man
some people already have eight points
it's difficult
okay this is an interesting line let's
play Knight f3
yeah I like the position always clicking
b1 yeah this is interesting let's take
care of first some weird structure want
to maneuver my knight back into play
I really have to manage my time h4
coming let's do this
maybe d5 coming to d5 95 takes
interesting I'm expecting this move and
then I'll play d5 like here I also take
and I'm up upon kind of offer the traded
bishops maybe not like this Bishop 9 h5
doesn't quite work let's move the knight
to d4 I like this position I'm holding
on to you 6 let's not hang anything can
i play that 6
let's defend interesting let's play c4
humans upon no it's doubled pawns
control the D file I want to play rook
d7 should be three I want to play C 5
min o c5 I probably have to play b5 okay
I like this now King C 3 defend can tray
the pair of Brooks told the file again
how do I crash through some b2
the King on b3 oh that's gonna be
annoying I hung up on know but something
we're open this is attacked
I feel slow yeah I could move I need
some miracle that's not gonna work
good game I like the position until
everything fell apart I need some moral
support in the chat I have zero points
I'm tied for 3500 place I played some
good players to be fair playing this guy
let's play oh I played them last night I
think
hey it's bits got some moral support
okay yeah
Oh Bishop e3 is a good move let's take
and castle still a game yeah he's
playing like the best continuation like
what to do
three nights let's play ninety-seven I'd
be sacking another pawn
more bits basically moral support from
owner enigma
so blocks worse but there is some
there's some complications like it's
kind of underdeveloped high pressure in
the center Queen takes Knight f6 wow if
I could take or I could play Knight here
let's take that is equal material
blockade
I just want to complete developments a
seven was kind of hanging I don't know
if I wanted to take it might be five
pawn storm might spawn storming to could
play this move I don't this move I want
to win the pawn
it's very complicated um Queeny 727 d6
open I can take the check
oh but he takes a bishop first
well maybe it's still okay rookie six
takes f7 Queen takes f7 d6 Ricky six
I've cleaned f1 threats this looks okay
to like weenie six picking up the pawn
go after this guy let's do this check
check I'll push the pawn whoa very
tricky it's a choke defend
he's playing creatively but slowly
yeah now this is winning okay I want a
game feel so good to win I'm know I'm
not in the top thousand but I'm
something okay let's position
dr. mater steam could be Carlsen
anonymously hopefully not all right
let's play aggressively so one minute to
two minutes can't waste any time it's
taking his time
taking a lot of time it's a complicated
position so many pawns are attacked now
we have a 4/9 d3 okay d3 is a bit
passive od6 wasn't a slip but thankfully
it was not a bad move you have to play
somewhat positionally it's like h6 I
want to take on f3 and then play my tea
for now I'm threatening both things
probably include c6 oh you'd let me fork
still lets me take the pawn
okay now my Knights will kind of drink
this looks really fun mean tactics
aren't everywhere double check winning
the Queen I'll win the rook in the end
that's nice and I'm up on time and
that's me okay not a bad game
I broke back into the top thousand 689
fine this guy let's play E for ya a lot
of these games if I can bazaar
I'll bezerk ooh I have six is not a
great move let's just develop I've three
minor pieces developed black has two
pawns developed might be hard to punish
this is a good song let's do this first
I will play Knight b5 and Bishop f4 if
Queen b8 I would play g3
I'm gonna go in and be like hyper
aggressive because this looks fun
threatening this and winning the Queen
maybe oh it's interesting move takes
takes still go for this
something's crazy move I think I'm
giving up two miners for a rook Baldwin
f7 and still be somewhat interesting
want to play this
this could actually be big trouble
yeah that's a good move please take the
bishop oh okay this is nice fell for the
trap our life is good just have to
manage the time winning a knight g6 I
just take it
okay that was a slightly questionable
position at some points but I came back
feel the Thunder I want berserk let's
play solid I'll play it London I have to
say I'm not feeling the Thunder let's
play Bishop each six first do this and
this this is a very nice attack I here
will come now there's so many fork ideas
everywhere I have four ideas to add
another attacker I could take h7 looks
good night will return here
that's good move though I could just
take care that all Queen h8 so many
threats
check yeah I don't really want to trade
Queens but it's just simple it's not
hang a rook try and show some technique
yeah thankfully my work is defended by
the Knights I cover c2 I'll win the b3
pawn d4 can be annoying
this pawns defended you're putting up
some resistance I have plenty of time
okay all right have some Street going
trying to break into the top hundred
there's almost 4,000 people playing
those
okay let's loser play this move I try
and win some quick games
what's the move here Queen d6 I think
threatening mates this is very difficult
to defend yeah
all right nice game player London this
time yeah we're going into some deep
theory Queen dxe5 I think is slightly
inaccurate it's been a while since I've
actually looked at this maybe Bishop c7
should have been played first let's play
the smooth threatening to take on
Mishima rook now Bishop c7 threatening
Knight B 3 Queen can't retreat it's a
fun line great for bliss I can't trap
the Queen Caroline takes 95 I mean
there's so many things attacking this
Knights the threat is to take take take
and trap the rook
kake's let's take first and play kinda
weird move but I want to play rook b5
and also maybe hit the pawn now I could
take takes takes I'll use attacking the
bishop though so if I take also take
their first let's take your first Kings
c8 coming then I take very weird
position now it's a good move
maybe this move and this move well when
I can move the bishop away with check no
idea what's going on you can't take my
rook has a Queen's pinned I can take you
take first Queen before I'm down the
exchange but I have comp take with the
bishop keep the defy little bit hmm
tap the pawn I'm just worse here though
it's unfortunate attack the pawn again
I'm down a lot of time to move over poke
around
not looking so good
good move yeah well played
I was really complicated position wait
you can't hear me hello hello you sure
the volume should be turned on okay
let's preserve sound is good okay
good to hear buzzer King
let's play some line come back this is
gonna be a long tournament let's move on
I win see - Wow
well he's playing fast let's play this
actually playing faster than me and I'm
the one who deserts ok bye I like the
position now now I don't and he's
playing very well
plus everything's falling let's do that
move I mean I have to set up some tricks
in the Knight to f5 put the Queen on d5
you put the bishop on b6 no Queen trade
let's take back all the pawns falling
safe King it should be a routine win
alright
that's a close game play at the opening
I played blundered early in the middle
game had to come back alright let's
fight d4 hey in England someone was
asking for this earlier let's play this
move will play bring chess really boring
chess make him fall asleep when I bring
the knight to c5 just any night looks
like a nice square probably this Knight
pawn can come to at three he's kind of
doing the same thing let's do this
pin the night
maybe she'll see fire
b5 will just be solid very tense
position let's preserve the vision might
play 95 at some points
maybe this idea I can't allow the ship
to you for the defending attacking 95
making things interesting takes takes
any tactics work here maybe not the
slide time advantage a3 is kind of
hanging it's quite at four
I want to bring the bishop to a for a
box taking a lot of time now this is
coming almost meat to do take wasn't
sure what to do there oh that was a
blender I have to come back oh my gosh I
keep wondering everything all crumbled
so quickly
okay I can't complain with the draw I
guess I mean I was so dead lost I kept
wondering pieces did not deserve to draw
that that's life
I'm almost in the top hundred man just
completely collapsed at some point
Chester little let's go taking a risk
through the past time
okay times a rook lift that's a fun line
should be a fun line III is weak mmm
this is gonna be fine
I think he sees it though Oh rook F 2
was the best try that was nice
wait you can barely hear me I can move
the mic like closer is this better
maybe this is better or you can yeah
turn your volume up let's to play this G
3
hey it's bits 200 bits from Bishop
something something f5 i 5 is a nice
line piece sacrifice line computer gives
like plus 0.5 in this position Queen f6
is not a move I've seen before I think
I'll sack the pawn play Bishop d2 yeah
of course in like bullets it's a bit
different but it still looks really fun
Queen h5 ideas it's so much initiative
it takes hmm
d4 let's take here first black can't
castle either way Queen up five ideas of
e5 white takes takes takes takes seems
very close to working as a sound better
usually don't have the mic this close
takes
yeah this is a big risk okay let's go
for this check and rookie one pintura or
pin bishop workout 5 to follow queen c6
rook d5 check King c8 king g1 are you
Ricky for two wait a minute takes hmm
plane to slow I have to prove something
here that's not good wait this is really
bad like my whole position is just
crumbling I liked the opening there any
tricks I resigned good game yeah my
attack didn't work I had to play quicker
and better okay let's play this move
play this line should be 5
this is kind of a risk and now I can do
this
95 ideas always King B 1 C 495 play 95
at the pond hmm now there's a weakness
Oh No
are you serious just blundered that okay
it's not over
that was completely not necessary now
it's actually gonna be a fights not
entirely sure how blocks gonna win this
or if I'm even worse let's play clear up
here just hunker down
let's move attack the pond throw in King
anyone I'm gonna be aggressive risky but
interesting
Ewan's a problem still might be horrible
ah got me to know and some fortress
going on that's difficult actually I
don't know if it was a fortress was
really unfortunate okay reverse Grand
Prix
I could have desert I just have to calm
down still have some tea
oh you wanna you want me to play a dutch
maybe I'll play a Dutch all I forgot to
change it back change this back to
playing there we go
apologies I played the first part of the
tournament in the wrong scene I wanna
play rook a8 push the pawn close things
down Bishop c4 ideas maybe have to watch
out for b3 start with this move defend
the pawn and this should work as I
attack the bishop
this bishop Kent doesn't have any legal
moves
let's pawn storm such heaven for the
minor pieces this would be a potential
mate
lift the rook yeah the night's gonna
find a square there's a simple plan of
putting one work on b3 the other work on
b5 get a plan didn't quite work so let's
go for the other plan putting the rook
on h8 and playing h4 that might not work
either cuz of bishops there
so here's other plan put the rook on e4
and then walk the king and bring the
King to d3 I'll be hung the pawn I
trusted him this is so hard for way to
defend ok GG Manos in the chat what
Solanas okay this guy's miserable I'll
remember or I'll try to remember to play
a dutch if I remember ok London time
yeah this is a fine line I like the
structure throw in each six want to play
this move maybe be five first maybe not
H four at some point to fish of each to
tack upon
there's some similarities to last game
these are pong weaknesses rook a seven
just kind of full domination now the
idea is to play Knight e5 or even 91 f3g
for mites almost trapped
not quite now I want to trap the bishop
he saw it let's play this month
the G file will be open soon can be
looking on each one maybe Bishop b4
would have been scary they're straight
bishops 94 defending e4 square this is
going slightly wrong but now slightly
rights very much right okay should be a
technical wind let's defend first push
the pass pawn
[Music]
okay oh man that's a lot of moving all
right well he's miserable too
approaching the halfway points
gonna be ultra aggressive wanna play p4
yeah this might backfire put the rook
here ooh
it backfired this is really bad
this is really bad keeping the rook on
the board though I have a trick that's
not gonna work I trick is to play g5 and
hoping when persons please on pissant
he did not Besant let's do this mmm
there goes my bishop and there goes my
king oh that was peaceful that's a
danger of buzzer King and playing
dubious chess okay both pawns are
attacked it should be for King you to
get the pawn the a3 prevent Bishop
before pin the night now the goal is to
play king d2 and double up on a G file
may be king e - kini - slightly safer
like before oh the rook was hanging
trusted my opponent let's play h4 if
takes work g7 threatening rook hh7 mate
that was a nice finish
try to make up for the previous game top
hundred again so prize money goes to the
top 12 so 48 points ok English let's
play this one reverse Grand Prix
was looking very pleasant
this is pinned this is attacked after
he's a threat tack the pinch Knights
Roque two ideas just so much pressure
all these things are targets I mean yeah
this is winning two pieces or the Queen
g3 is not hanging okay
GG that was a nice win 36 points okay so
we have a bullet game being ambitious
being very ambitious in such domination
hey it's bits 250 bits from you got Jess
thanks for the bits I can't resist this
oh that was almost going to be made
where is it mate is this this is made
into what I mean - so beautiful
okay no time to waste still have
catching up to do
41 points okay playing the sky I am
versus I am go for this opening again
this is playable queen d4 rook f1 while
so confident do this down upon that it's
kind of weird position can't take on a
two yet take me to does this work this
mites no that doesn't work either yeah
it's difficult position just have to
deal with being down upon hoping for a
five building up some pressure
checking the night yeah this is just
domination despite my pawn cube still
alive kind of down to pawns I have a
night the only night on the board put
the bishop there now the goal is to get
the rook over and made them on b3 put
the rook their 96 coming tricky move
doesn't do too much though let's take
first put this guy back mmm there goes
my bishop
I want to invade someone last trick
one last trick please or just flag
how does he stop queen c1 am I just
meeting I might just be meeting well the
car will the turn around we see five
ideas
safety first yay oh well come back okay
no time to waste
let's play c6 weird opening
[Music]
okay efore is under my control play rook
b8 first h5 lineart i wanna play f6 now
oh I'm winning upon I think LC takes
play this first Queen d7 that's a decent
move might be losing a pawn now hmm not
the most pleasant but I do have my
Knights
oh this is gonna be really bad or my
tricks
I'm playing a 2700 almost time to resign
but not yet
okay resign
all right that was rough 42nd place 45
points the winner has okay I need like
ten more points to break into the top
ten might be doable we're halfway
through the tournament you haven't
played too many of these lines with f6
that's a move let's play this move
anyway except the double pawns
playing very risky giving up a to hoping
this attack works play king d2 at some
points always play g4 we need love hey
chess here to give me bits for playing
g5 as making so much money last night
playing g5 as other free piece what
wants to play wants to play Knight to e4
that's interesting that you for I've was
very interesting maybe I can take take
first it's not a great position for me
though oh maybe I'm turning this so it's
still interesting there's a big ste 3
Queen takes c6 work f7 could just be bad
I'll go into the sign I'll be down in
exchange but there might be counterplay
squinting one check yeah and then like
Bishop my bishop move wash of D for
solid move rook spinned of Queen here I
do this rekka fate Bishop c5 and there's
Queen h6 and end then we trade it's
complicated
up on time that's a good thing
oh maybe this just checked my calendar
for today okay good um H or H maybe H
three solid move wow that's that's a
terrible move he resigns before I can
take and me them okay
unexpected gift as he buzzer Kabul mmm
this line going for the tack very early
because why not you five start by taking
it pal Castle open D file think the
goals to play h5
some lines Knight takes rook takes pawn
takes that's none of it hmm yeah my
attack isn't like crushing but it's
pleasant keep Queens on the board
I want to invade six before I have
Bishop c4 G for ideas 296 I'd years now
also 92 ideas such a confusing position
always play king b1 right why it's pure
my knight what's pinned not sure Bishop
c4 a while such a gift
yeah everything's gonna fall apart cuz
his knight is pinned even though my
pawns pinned in the end now I'm winning
the Knights
o my Knights still hanging forgot about
that by strolling the night I have Queen
here to 9f8 safety first keep an eye on
this pond
training I was fighting rook takes d7
interesting move actually kind of
annoying move for me
Oh F for I open up this nice oh but he
has c4 amend this is still a fight but
he didn't play c4 and now I'm meaning
okay not a bad game let's preserve okay
I like this already g6
my knife belongs on d7 not the bishop
bishop c8 looks passive but let's take
first in the 97 96 yeah this is slightly
annoying to weather the storm
put the bishop restricting the Knights
things should probably go somewhere safe
forgot this pawn was hanging we both
forgot can probably take with this guy
keep things closed
I lost a pawn not the end of the world
please fall for mate
please know I flagged yeah he played a
good game I go to jail
d3 is my child opening when I'm a 34
now this is playable I think
I'm not at that structure we can trade
play series soon that's a good move
gonna be down upon to defend left on c3
a three
King up - yeah okay I'm just playing a
position down upon no big deal pawn
storm
g5y not an hour ok jaden Bishop III his
idea throw on the Chuck not the towel
wait wherever he moves as Bishop I'll
move my Bishop to attack his Bishop and
then I'll have a hopefully better nd
take some b5 and rook c6 win one pond
when the Jeep on probably
how do I make progress that's good move
maybe I'll just play this in game mm
let's take this first to go for the Judy
flag oh no wait
takes takes just an opposition you can't
take now it's winning it's completely
winning
okay back to tournaments that's gonna be
hard to break through loser hey it's
bits from shooter 1776
thanks for the bits
takes let's take it maybe this move in
95 the squares week the square is also
week neither three has to be played lost
rookie one maybe no always Castle always
meet hey back to tournament mm-hmm I'll
he's 18 place okay let's beat him was
this line okay scotch will play this
line Queen h4 Queen G floor just trade
rookie hates there should be six coming
85 coming age six monday 57 hold on
interesting move take some bishop I'm
going to simplify if paan takes maybe 95
first rook takes i play my f5 keeping
time advantage well
looks questionable maybe it's playable
oh there's a nice trick if he takes I
play this in this so I'm winning upon
yeah always castle we got three Bishop
g4 always play off six free pawn I'll
throw in this move see where the rook
goes I don't know if I want to take
let's take anyway we betrayed some rooks
and then yeah there's some trick takes
here and I win this pawn that's my F
pawn will be dangerous at least one of
that ones play f3 yo you're alive
yes congratulations
wait f2 I have to focus sorry yeah f2
doesn't work oh okay this is gonna be a
fight
oh no I'll have a g4 though what is
going on
f2 moves don't work I always play Bishop
f1
it was really confusing position man I'm
too far away and count your place on how
this is bad this is really bad I resign
back to tournaments oh I tried my best
okay let's buzzer cuz I'm on tilts he's
not really bitter Keable but there's
only one way to find out if someone's
miserable oh that was bad I know pong
alright see ya thanks
get this pawns attackable my day 696 is
interesting so ideas of this to trap the
Queen
not yet trapped start with this anyway
g4 g v why not when I have some tactics
against this night I'm not seeing
anything immediate the rooks III ideas
playbook c3 first confusing position
play this now ninety six three nights
this is working out
[Music]
now b3 is nice things are kind of pinned
Oh Brooke takes you far as a mouse slip
but wait what takes and check okay it's
gonna be a time scramble to bring the
king to d2 got careless there hey you
didn't play rook c3 which is good I can
kind of safely move around as I'm bait
from behind watch the pond good try okay
berserk win against the 2300 so I'm
coming back to do the work again so now
we have bullet shells
yeah we're adding this in this like
bizarre King stage just have to rack up
the points this is looking nice very
nice mmm not your official basics
actually works there about such a nice
position
let's keep the pressure Wow
so bold where's the wind maybe just this
Queenie one Bishop g4 let's just take
this Bishop g4 eventually also the rook
can be taken
there we go
okay need more wins like that Feker ice
winning streak until the last game 60
points let's go work again London time
g4 slight wing b3 chuck b g4 now g5
let's bring the knight in Koine three
pin the pond like g4 invade squares on
poisson ticks maybe I'm winning upon
trade Queens there we go
it's kind of annoying let's do this 95
kg for I win the pond we could trade
okay this is almost a mating that before
and rook h1 mate okay climbing the ranks
23rd place I need to get to 12th place
to win money all about that money okay
let's break it down
everyone's working it's nice because
they'll be quicker games
this is gonna be slightly annoying okay
we'll just trade everything on some
playable position I think this is okay
trade oh maybe this is not okay do you
want a beer it be one Bishop takes not
looking great
yeah that's a good move to to do
still trying to fight take say seven
ideas
31 km/h to my Black has weak pawns
everywhere
we're winning a piece Riki formally move
can take let's play this position you
can't attack you - right away oh that's
a move though let's just take a good
night he has a rook Knights are so
tricky okay didn't deserve to win that's
terrible opening but kind of work size
17 place please was work back he's not
busy working back okay French defense
time
I've never lost to this guy four and a
half to half lifetime score wanna play
Bishop here keep the bishops you see
five have to play aggressively c-4
before a five why not double up on a
file Bishop here's maybe sacking
potential g5 potential or gate six
potential take your first maybe not the
best move but a move back play on both
sides King g7 was a non-slip I should
see it coming I want to give up a file
though never get to his squares are
being controlled
let's defend the pawn can take that
tacking defending want to play work out
seven does this work better work maybe
working there we go okay have a breather
cooldown half hour left top 20 still
17th place night King is probably
dominating okay let's do this
yeah this is a fun line point 94
96 if he takes whoa okay there's some
for coming or that it's technically a
fork 52 and bishops III with a skewer
chief or always play g4 to h4 click this
move tech and then at three Ricky 196
yeah it's a move rook d8 I can probably
take play this move what's going on here
what is this position kind of one in the
pond oh that's a really good move or is
it a position opposition breakthrough
ah it's way too slow way too slow okay
I mean I'm within striking distance I
mean four points away from tenth so most
of these final games will probably just
be bollock games hoping for some hope
Bishop g4 ideas over the things pinned
it's good move though can't trade Queens
I like to invade from behind
not sure what I'm threatening he's
calling my bluff
yeah well played okay so he's going for
the points okay there we go ah why am i
playing so fast and carelessly stay calm
stay focused only down a piece and a
pawn but both bishops are out of play so
I'm essentially up at night
not looking so great kept the rook
that's a great move okay
struggling 22nd place the zerk still
time to catch up
let's still work I think this still
works
this is winning some nice opening breath
you get zero money for 14th place
unfortunately let's take this I'm up a
piece this King where's my meat to do
this first
after three let's do this
threatening f3 and rook takes e5 that's
not yet mate
maybe g3 running rookie five mate oh
it's not yet me still putting up
resistance
okay all right I need the streak streak
will start helping but it's not easy
like every game and playing someone good
except maybe this game he's doing well
1956 place player line B 3 is very
questionable play 5 immaculate pawn
chain play this move the nylon b1 is
completely stuck
you can't save itself on the play e5
oh that's a decent move keep attacking
this he's playing well this is very
strong play by white there we go this is
okay Queen age six I can take free queen
finally he blunders okay good game
Oh next game please buzzer no not buzzer
King okay gonna be a challenge piece I
have a line I'm comfortable with
so the plan is usually rook-a for it to
be for and rook a1 to a3 to be 3 PI g4
here let's move to back with night
oh the pawns hanging forget about that
it's still okay maybe just down upon to
take a knight c5 ideas
am I getting mated maybe that move yet
getting made it that's ugly though oh my
Brooke is just here last any last tricks
still need hope yeah it's tough okay
really trying play this line double
fianchetto Queenie three coming
over to fending g51 played Bishop f6
next what does this position take stakes
yeah I could move oh this is really bad
I can't defend can i counter-attack
I've been down a piece before usually
doesn't end that great I resign this is
tough it's tough as irking when they
don't desert back and at this point like
I'm trying to break into the top group
so I have to play aggressively after
berserk have to get a streak this looks
reasonable click this position
you
[Music]
it's kind of pinned
94 expected keep Queens on the board
I take twice this has got to be good
down a piece now that three could come
[Music]
takes takes maybe nine of three like
rook rook e8 this looks good
I'll be fancy
that's okay wait it's frozen what's
going on okay that was weird
I was really weird
thankfully I have enough time just don't
freeze again okay it's never happened
where it just like freezes thankfully I
had enough time to like refresh 18th
place so it sits within distance I'm
four points away from 12 but they're
also going to gain points as human
beserk away friends a bizarre okay
blood game Budapest come on see - I'm
interesting the brook lifts early let's
play d6 keep the rook on the side let's
play Bishop e6 97 why not add six takes
takes
this could be really annoying throw in a
check first I have to play f6 oh this is
so unfortunate
and I'm running to the queenside take a
free pawn Bishop Bishop h6 I guess
attack the pawn check up on some more
take the pawn defend my pawn push the
pawn this is so bad still might be three
ideas I resign
okay it's rough ten minutes left working
okay easy win hopefully it's already
completely winning most people play
Queen a 5 or a 5 here g5 expected
I need as many final games as possible
even if I get 12th place it's only $10
but still the pride and glory might have
to win this game on time
Bishop c4 ideas or p1 ideas
let's take first
Rippy one-take here
Queen Queen d4 should be playable just
up the exchange okay put the rock on d4
King is boxed in
kind of
and I'm just going for the flag okay
where am I
there I am 87 I'm playing super Alice
she wanted beserk back oh he doesn't
know how the berserk probably that's
unfortunate whoo checkmate
okay 15 to 15th place catching up okay
taking some risk free Queen so many
gifts everyone's fatigued and burnt out
BAM okay
catching up 11th place it's amazing how
quickly you get the streak good things
happen knockers irking or shall i beserk
let's beserk you want a buzzer back yes
hmm play this move d5 square will be
mine they work on some good square pin
the pond but not really attack the rook
very complicated not sure what's going
on that's what's going on mm-hmm
check play King g8 safety first
oh I'm just getting need it oh dear
there's nothing okay I have to keep my
my place there's a lot of people with 94
Bishop c5 to 83 I guess counter-attack
takes night b5e what's going on
takes takes when upon I guess I'm going
to smooth this night almost trapped
almost trapped can take takes let's do
this move not a bad position actually
down the exchange but lights probably
better close good idea free night
winning like all the rooks told you okay
alright its twelfth place
Grand Prix unintended a live with it
strong Bishop please play Rick do you on
no back for coming they choose hanging I
take this that works
good move like this in King h6 eg5 even
are you serious I'm getting needed no
okay one last game I'm in 14th place I
have to be work are you sure he's not
resorting back okay let's get him with
some trap
this is playable wait really need the
buzzer Quinn I don't think there's
enough time in the tournament to finish
this game so sad really going all out I
resign I want to play one quick game
oh they're closed I shouldn't resigned
well there goes my tournaments I wasn't
gonna win that position just she's
strong ah close fight 16 I'll finish in
the top 20 at least
okay yeah there is
at the very end he was just trying to
break into 12th place I don't know
people can see the prize my baby now
yeah so these are the prizes I was
fighting for the like coveted 12th place
of ten dollars but okay that was fun
played the whole tournament Wow what
kinds of strategies do you employ to
reduce your stress while playing chess I
feel like every time I play I have
trouble calming down I mean part of it
is just experience like the way to do
something calmly is to just put in the
time there's some tenant 10,000 hour
rule you spend 10,000 hours doing
anything you you should by that point be
pretty calm doing it meditation could
help I mean losing a lot can help
there's a point in my life where I was
when I when I lost I would get very
upset but eventually you just become
maybe not used to it but you can come
like no I'm like it shouldn't affect you
in such a way where you smash the
keyboard or any other expensive
equipment yeah the Malcolm Gladwell rule
that's good book this is called outliers
I've sweaty palms
not too bad evil majin buu asking what
am i screaming again I have a screen
schedule can pull it up you can go to my
website pull it up on my thermometer
it's just I am rosen.com /schedule you
can find the upcoming events today is a
12 tomorrow the hyperbolic shield arena
man I'll be doing a lot of bullets
that'll be interesting 30 second chests
then I'll schedule some more events
after after tomorrow if I want to study
the London are there any side lines you
would recommend to prioritize I actually
recommend with any opening prioritizing
main lines first
gillece get a starting points learn the
lines that you run into most frequently
and this requires like some observation
like if you're learning a new opening
make an effort like play 5 10 games in
the opening save all of them to database
or study and then then do some analysis
do some reflection because inevitably
you'll you'll run into people who do
similar things and then you want to
prioritize what those things are but
London specific sidelines it all depends
will black place
yeah I'll probably do another Q&A stream
in the future or I answer or these
questions in more detail I think I'm
done playing for the teh I played a lot
of chess
thanks for invitations oh do I do
anything else for a living I have a
pretty flexible lifestyle I mean when
you say for a living
assume you mean work I have some events
coming up and I'll be photographing at
the protest league finals in San
Francisco um I'll be doing a few summer
camps in June and July I'll be doing
commentary for the US chest twitch
stream it's National scholastic
Tournament in Nashville next month yeah
if you guys want to come to San
Francisco I had limited room in my
suitcase actually I'm not taking a
suitcase I'm just taking a backpack yeah
I have limited room in my backpack but
okay there's other ways to get there um
yeah I'll I admire the I admire videos I
don't necessarily binge them but I enjoy
watching them he has very very distinct
style
he's been mean he's someone that I kind
of look up to and like building an
audience it's done a lot of things
correctly with just having uh having a
very loyal kind of fan base and there's
a lot of things he's knowledgeable about
that I feel like other chests content
creators could learn from in terms of
just consistency finding good content
interacting with the community so yeah
great person for chess